tu as lu ça veut dire quoi dans l'temps
à chivu main juste pourra-t-on pour
leurs formes attraction instinctive pour
les baby boomers selon moi plus pour les
bulles comme son pote en ouvert d'esprit
il
l'expression est une réponse à une
attaque condescendante que les
générations qui a précédé les plus
jeunes alors intérêt envers les
changements climatiques et tout ça c'est
une expression pour dix rebelles à
écouter nos felletin il faut âgées on ne
connaît pas l'origine de l'expression
hockey boomer mais elle a été
popularisée en 2019 par cette vidéo
partagée sur l'application secteur
c'est énormément partager et repris le
vraiment discours qui est plus
paternaliste et plus condescendant
l'égard de la génération qui est un peu
à peu est idéale celle qui a sorti
l'expression des réseaux sociaux
c'était là chloé swarbrick une
politicienne de nouvelle zélande
elle se faisait chahuté par un collègue
au parlement doit lendl alors qu'elle
tenait un discours sur les changements
climatiques a calmement
depuis cette intervention en novembre
ok boomer est utilisé à toutes les
sauces principalement sur les réseaux
sociaux
toc toc instagram facebook twitter tout
s'y passe
on a vu apparaître le mot clic
hockey-balle 1 ainsi que des mêmes et
des dif à la tête
une chanson est même consacré à cette
expression une personne âgée ton qui
fait un commentaire un peu déplacée vers
le très haut qui vous marquent enfin si
le temps ne l'utilisent pas notre
respect certains perçoivent l'expression
comme une insulte
d'autres l'utilisent plutôt à la blague
c'est une joke le suis pas vraiment pour
pour la petite histoire les baby boomers
sont nés après la deuxième guerre
mondiale
entre 1946 et 1960 les millé nario 1
regroupe une partie des génération y et
z ceux qui sont nés entre 1982 et 2004 j
1 go qui est vraiment un bon marché -
michel barrette et clame haut et fort sa
fierté d'être un baby boomer la
nostalgie qui s'était tellement de forme
d'antan petite passe son temps à
raconter le passé plutôt que de recevoir
l'expression ok boomer comme une offense
l'humoriste y voit un échange
intergénérationnel très sain il ya un
espèce de face à face qui n'existaient
pas mon époque bon mon père était de
cette génération là qui était pas très
jojo régler avec les enfants j'ai un
système figure d'autorité jeu n'a pas
été là pour vous écouter à tal afar un
poteau table dans la dame n'y avait pas
vraiment de discussion et s'il y avait
un début de discussions s'était
automatiquement un espèce de
confrontation parce que écoute
apprendront pas tomber a fait des
enfants
aujourd'hui on est ailleurs l'expression
lui a même inspiré un tout dernier
spectacle appelé l'humour de ma vie mais
qui a bien failli s'intituler à pied
boomer c'est un show ne s'agit un show
où on revient dans le passé et où je
prouve sur scène comme c'était l'fun
et comme c'est encore la fin des tabous
main actuellement il ya peut-être 60 des
10 e maurice en tournée sur 70 et si on
a peut-être trop que son débours main
alors qu'on est encore la parole qu'on a
un auditoire devant nous sur ma personne
pour défendre notre génération
je suis tellement content d'être la
porte étendard des boumeurs partout au
québec michel barrette considère que
vivre sa jeunesse est plus compliqué
aujourd'hui mais aussi que la nouvelle
génération est plus avisé les
ils sont beaucoup plus brillant qu'on
l'était à l'époque - 13 ans je n'ai pas
des discours de mon fils de 13 ans parce
que justement l'accès facile de
l'information l'accès à l'internet jeu
benbouchta olivesi ben ouais bah c'est
compliqué j'écoute mon fils qui est très
humble par les policiers de deux
rapports hommes-femmes de ce crash qui
revient non je parlais pas de 113 ans
peut-être que je vais être au poignet ce
bon petit android est passé formé sur le
reste dans l'est alors bravo les jeunes
[Musique]